you love me our Tana mojo and Jake Paul
engaged you sent me a voice memo like
admitting that you wanted to be like Tim
I celebrated her 21st birthday with a
party that was so lit it ended with a
proposal cake and a diamond ring okay
let's back that up the youtuber counted
down to her milestone birthday on
Instagram with a series of picks
including this scantily clad shot of her
with some balloons and these almost
not-safe-for-work snaps posing with a
birthday cake that reads I'm legal
[ __ ] Ventana and Jake took a party
bus to Las Vegas with her closest pals
and naturally documented the whole ride
including they're uncomfortable PDA
later the two headed out for a night in
Sin City where Jake presented Tanna with
a massive cake that had the words will
you marry me Tanna written on it then
Tama shared this clip to her Instagram
story that's a massive sparkler sitting
pretty on that finger
Tanna shared the news on Twitter writing
Jake just proposed
and I'm dah dah dah dah dah engaged doc
doc doc I thought when one Twitter user
asked a question that we're all thinking
is this a joke here's what Tana had to
say it's not I'm engaged
holy [ __ ] not only did Jake seemingly
bite Anna some serious bling he also
dropped some serious cash on this gift
for Tana
yep that's Tana posing with the 22 year
old and her brand-new Mercedes g-wagon
complete with a red ribbon thanks babe
I got you swipe up what
okay let's sidebar to discuss that a
g-wagen cost upwards of one hundred and
twenty five thousand dollars one hundred
and twenty-five thousand dollars people
that is some serious cash Oh both Jake
and Tana documented the surprise on
social media
Jake captioned this shot happy birthday
BB well Tana shared this pic writing
never give up on your dreams kids thank
you baby
wanna teach me to drive or many skills
our whole thing is you know better in
each other better each other not down to
teach you I'm just like do you use my
car definitely have a car okay this is
wild because according to a video that
Tana posted a few weeks ago titled Jake
Paul teaches me how to drive in his
250,000 dollar car she can't actually
well Drive really never driven before
I've driven like twice oh my god my gosh
goodness how far should my foot be from
the gas which one's the gas oh you
should be me me Jake recently set the
record straight about his relationship
with Tana in his new series team 10
uncut is why I love tender because we
are like the same exact person the way
we think rumor said the two were dating
first got stirred up when she posted a
snapchat in his bed and
I'm Jake's gonna say that I'm doing this
for Klout which is so annoying
like holy no I I came over to hang out I
looked cute I took a snapchat story I'm
sorry your beds famous like I know she
did this on purpose like she's not gonna
admit it after talking to Tana on the
phone the two decided to just go with it
ride it out and play it up to get more
views this is like puttin our laps to
like get some cloud up you know it
happened we can either sit around and
[ __ ] about it or we can like make the
best of a crazy situation I don't know
hmm of course et had to ask Jake and his
brother Logan about the dating rumors
when we caught up with them in May he's
mainly into me but like I don't I've
been keeping it low-key Jake more went
public with it yeah yeah there was
rumors that maybe you guys went on a
first date is that weird but they did it
any it Jake this is a better match if
I'm being honest yeah we should do each
other's girlfriends I guess time will
tell on this one and we'll be right here
to keep you up to date on all things
Tana and Jake so keep it locked on et
until next time I'm Hallie Stephens bye
for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]